china fighter will
jet will flower taiwan to declare
sovereignty state media says newsweek
story chinese fighter will flower towns
under declaration of
relations between washington and taipei
continue to improve a prominent state
media figure set after beijing
sent 25 warplanes toward the island on
monday chief editor of china's
nationalistic communist party newspaper
the global times said the people's
liberation army would step up military
pressure in the event of a further
warming of u.s taiwan ties
if taiwan forces open fire that will be
the moment of
all-out war across the taiwan strait the
people's republic of china claims
ownership of democratic taiwan despite
having never governed
it in seven decades since its founding
after the chinese civil war taiwan
continues to be a run as the de facto
state that maintains several unofficial
yet crucial global partners
in an ambiguous existence known as the
status quo
adam well we touched on this i believe
in the last podcast
about china and their relationships with
their surrounding countries taiwan being
specific
um we might be here in america this this
is all this all comes down to
perspective and putting yourself in
someone else's shoes
we here in america think well who cares
taiwan whatever
this is a huge deal for china huge deal
for china
so on the on the outside perspective you
know we have a list of topics people
we're going through our live we got the
million different things we're dealing
with blm and antifa we got things going
on here that we care about
we hear taiwan uh whatever whatever is
going on myanmar gives a [ __ ] yep
for china this is a huge deal this is
the
quote unquote proverbial red line that
they don't want anybody crossing
so you know they talk about in world war
one
when the archduke ferdinand was
assassinated and that
you know spouted off this powder keg
that
led to world war one which eventually
led to world war ii yada yada yada yada
this is the type of thing you know knock
on wood cross your fingers that could
potentially lead
to a world war iii where something small
that affects a country
more than you understand can lead to
something massive and for china
apparently it's this taiwan thing i i
did this is basically
a 50 year old byproduct of the
revolution
and chiang kai-shek you know going
across
you know what you have here it's
unresolved and
to those of us in the west you should
really think of it as east and west
germany
that was unresolved for so long right
and then there was reunification
and so after world war ii we had this
split and we had berlin the berlin wall
and everything that goes with that
and china sees this the same way this is
the way they see it
that was once part of us it should still
be part of this and this is what's
what's going on and you know if taiwan
i would as a matter of fact i was in
taipei taiwan um
on october 8th to 10th and on
this goes back 1999
and at my hotel i hear rumbling outside
on the morning of october 10th it was
kind of funny and they called the double
10 festival
10 10 october 10th and it was
the celebration of their independence so
there was a lot and i saw
i saw tanks out there and military
things in the street it was it was not
the russian military this is in taiwan
this is in taiwan
it was not a russian military may day
where everybody would you pull up taiwan
on the map
where they're like clapping politely but
you're you're supposed this is what year
this is 99 okay and so this bible is
called the double 10 festival happens
every year in
taiwan um taiwan double ten day right
there at the top
and it's sunday october 10th it's a
national day republic of china
public holiday annually see and what
they do is they celebrate their
independence
there is a lot of patriotism in the
street i saw it there was like this
there were parades there was activities
there was military in the street but it
wasn't military like russian mayday like
power military it was celebration like
when we had planes flying over the super
bowl you know i mean it was that kind of
celebration and stuff and so there is a
lot of pride
now of four generations in taiwan of
people
who feel wait we're independent i'm
taiwanese
and we're independent and china's like
no this is like world war ii
reunification
of germany i want that back
look at even the map right now i mean
obviously hong kong is in the news
because hong kong is
attached to mainland china it's sort of
like a peninsula on the on the um
south well the same thing happened in
hong kong look at taiwan
it's an island off of china is that
right kai might look at seeing that
right
yeah okay so from a
geographical standpoint taiwan is not
even attached to china so i can see
why would they but here's what i want
you to do i want you to go to the
heritage
index of economic freedom do you have
that up heritage index of economic
freedom
this is a site that shows you which
countries
are the most economically free countries
in the world go to see all rankings
to the right bottom right bottom right
right there
okay check this out close the okay free
meaning 100 to 80 how free they are
number one is singapore
number two is new zealand then australia
then switzerland and ireland
freest countries in the world okay let's
keep going
who's number six i think six or six is
taiwan wow
okay taiwan is free freer than america
then it's uk then it's estonia then
canada then marked in iceland
then georgia then mauritius then
uh united arab emirates then lithuania
you still don't have us by the way
netherlands finland luxembourg chile
united states united states is behind
uae think about that then he got sweden
malaysia let's go to the other side uh
japan south korea austria israel israel
czech republic norway
germany latvia qatar armenia armenia
shout out to armenia 30 seconds cyprus
kazakhstan bulgaria
malta belgium hello john 38. now we're
going to moderately free
spain bahrain poland thailand romania
uruguay jamaica
you see all these countries there jordan
bahamas costa rica
guatemala turkey 76. where's turkey 76.
oh you're about to see it as you go
lower and lower russia's 92 by the way
look at the main countries russia is 92
france is 64.
mexico 65 okay italy tanzania uh
uh 93 el salvador 94 greece 96
now you're going to mostly unfree go
ahead okay honduras south africa
benin ghana trinidad gambia nigeria
uganda china 107. 107. uzbekistan
mostly phone free egypt burma and you
see some of these countries okay along
with
lots of uh look at brazil brazil 143
afghanistan 146. that's freaking
argentina 140. 149.
pakistan 152. okay belize
tom 114 belize lebanon 154 haiti
india 121 is what
india is okay go lower now let's see the
one that says
repressed gotcha see if you see any big
company countries here
algeria iran 168 cuba 176
north korea last venezuela second to
last
then it's cuba the bottom three that are
actually ranked are north korea
venezuela and cuba
and go below it go below it go below it
you got iraq libya
lichtenstein somalia syria and yemen
here's what's crazy
out of cuba venezuela and south north
korea which of those three you think is
most likely
to be mostly free which of those three
things is most likely to be free
venezuela cuba
or north korea i have my guess what do
you think
well it's not north korea so not north
korea let's say that now
uh venezuela i'm going to say cuba i
think cuba is more likely to be free
than venezuela uh i it's just a hunch
i think it's closer i think it's you
know the influence i think venezuela is
second and i think north korea's true
but the point is going back to the
taiwan conversation
go all the way to the top china doesn't
want taiwan to have an emergency also
look also how uh this is five and then
it goes to twenty five i mean it's a
dramatically different gap
between the three a little bit yeah
versus any other country comparable it's
a dramatic camp
yeah i would love to see at the very
very very top um
and pat had a great point but the guy
killed two cousins in his brother
what the qualifications are for being
free quote unquote like did they give a
yeah read oh this well here it is rule
of law
so they're they're out there government
size regulatory efficiency open markets
trade freedom investment freedom
business freedom fiscal household
but by the way they have it on three
under each so rule of law
is property rights uh judicial
effectiveness government integrity then
you got government size tax burden
government spending fiscal health
regulatory efficiency business freedom
labor freedom
monetary freedom then you got trade
freedom investment freedom financial
freedom it's not so go to us
i want to see government integrity for
the u.s i'm going to see our score there
number two
20. go ahead and click on us open open
our card
here we go let's see what we're
excelling at we're sucking out okay
monetary freedom we're doing well in
fiscal health 35 that's a terrible score
by the way to be at 34.9
open markets trade freedom okay
government spending 62
tax burden 76. interesting when you look
at this
judicial effectiveness effectiveness
government integrity 76.8
its overall score has degrees by 1.8
points primarily because of a decline in
fiscal health
yeah you're printing money the united
states is ranked third among 32
countries so america's recent so why
would china want taiwan to stay free
they wouldn't want
to taiwan to stay free because taiwan
politically and philosophically is the
complete
opposite that's correct of what china so
the more taiwan excels
and people from china have a place to
leave to the more that makes china look
bad so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you